august last year it was like right cool
let's do this properly real quick let's
give it a go we'd set up an
infrastructure now because obviously we
tried i tried to rumble [ __ ] walk really
with the american stuff originally but
then as the business grew and we started
hiring people we had people in positions
it made more sense to them be able to do
it so we started that in august this
year decided on austin as the location
it's just a tech hub for like for the us
so many startups a lot of good
technology businesses it just has become
like one of the go-to places in america
for technology what was the strategy
what was like how are you going to crack
into this market we went a different way
about it i was a big fan of your podcast
and i just thought you know what let's
do much more community-led approach so
so what was the first step with that i
went on meetup.com okay found that we
wanted to focus on a specific area
specific type of uh business technology
that's specific to business so fintech
and shaw tech okay found all different
meetup groups or event groups that was
uh in the area contacted the organizers
spoke to them about where come to us and
we'd love to sponsor co-organizers help
you run some events was that the
outreach was it hey this is what we do
we'd love to help or support in some way
yeah yeah yeah so look we're we've come
to austin and we focus on this sector
yeah yeah and yeah really really keen to
be part and embed ourselves within the
community and um how's that received
really well really really well yeah so
then managed to start co-organizing and
sponsoring a few events
which then led to speaking online within
the forum on meetup.com and people
saying i would like to have this person
or this person do a talk or help me
organize round tables i went out to
austin and done a panel
um meet up there then that developed
into i would like to hear from this
person so i didn't contact them so
people my group would like to hear from
you so we started the podcast yeah
adjusting tech leaders and then from
there started building up a name
within the area and then work people
just sort of just gravitated towards us
and we're happy to work with us because
it's in the what we're doing there
[Music]
one